people of the internet retroarch and who
are here i'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell and we are
back with another hogwarts legacy video
and today i have what i think is a very
interesting question about the canon and
it's regarding something that troy
levitt said a dev who previously worked
on hogwarts legacy in one of his recent
interviews but before we get to that
though let's talk about the latest rumor
roundup yes i know you guys are
wondering you've been hitting me up on
twitter you've been sending me messages
what do i think about all of these march
rumors that are seemingly circulating
around hogwarts legacy look i'll be
completely honest with you guys i don't
think anybody knows
i think no one knows except for
avalanche as i've tried to explain a
couple of times on different videos that
i do here i actually work in marketing
not related to the video game industry
but i do work in marketing and even if
one of these supposed twitter insiders
actually has a source the information
that they have can change very rapidly
and it also depends on who they are
getting the information from when it
comes to marketing yes as a marketer you
love a nice clean calendar when you can
say here's exactly when this
announcement's gonna hit here's when
we're gonna release this we're gonna
have this press release we're gonna
release this to the media on this date
and it all works out nice and smooth
however anyone who works in marketing
knows that this is not how it works at
least not all the time because there's
always other things happening that are
going to affect that this could be
little things this could be big things
but my overall point here is that even
if account ngt or robert serrano or
whomever you may find on twitter that's
talking about hogwarts legacy even if
they actually do have some legitimate
piece of information it could absolutely
change and so that's why i just don't
put a whole lot of stock in this whole
insider game that goes on twitter
because at some point they're going to
be right and to me i mean march makes as
good a sense as any i think the most
credible piece we have here is that troy
levitt in response to alex on podcast
now he actually left a comment on one of
alex's videos where alex was talking
about all of these march rumors that
we're hearing and you gotta keep in mind
that troy has been removed from the
project for a while which he himself
said i have no inside information on
this however to him the timing would
feel right and that is because of the
fact if you go to the avalanche website
right now if you go to the hogwarts
legacy website you will see that they
are still saying 2022. and also the last
official word from avalanche was them
promising that more news was coming in
2022 so here we are in the third month
of the year the marketing for fantastic
beasts is really starting to ramp up
right now but where is hogwarts legacy
is it part of the fantastic beasts
marketing plan or do they want to get
that out of the way first and then have
hogwarts legacy have its own dedicated
time personally this is just my opinion
but i think it would be a huge mistake
to wait until the summer to say anything
at all i really think to put an
effective marketing plan in place for a
property like harry potter the type of
marketing that this deserves they really
need to start talking about this game
and soon i mean we have right now what
is the fourth most viewed video on the
entirety of playstation's official
youtube channel i want you to think
about that for a second i mean that is
absolutely bonkers insane and it's not
even a first-party title i mean this is
something that's going to be on xbox and
pc as well and yet here it is getting
ready to surpass spider-man in fact by
the time this video is out it may have
already surpassed the spider-man trailer
as being the number three video on the
playstation account however if you look
around online there's only the die hards
like us talking about this game no
insults to those of you on the harry
potter subreddit i'm reading on there
daily as well but it really feels like
it is a small group of us there who are
talking about this game every day i feel
like the vast majority of those 28
million views that the original trailer
has on youtube are from the more
mainstream harry potter audience who
have almost completely forgot about this
game at this point in fact they may even
be confusing it with the magic awaken
game that just had some big news a few
weeks ago about that it's supposedly
coming out in the u.s soon they acted
like it was right around the corner and
then took all our emails and then
silence i haven't heard anything about
it so i have no idea what's going on
there hopefully that one is coming soon
as well so well i know to us who are
constantly looking for hogwarts legacy
news and updates and those of you who
watch this channel regularly it may seem
to you like yeah they would probably be
fine if they waited until the summer and
did kind of a big marketing push then
for a holiday release would that be
enough time to reignite that mainstream
harry potter audience personally again
this is just my opinion as a marketer
myself i think it is a huge missed
opportunity if they let march and april
go by where you have a mainstream harry
potter audience going to see a new movie
and you say absolutely nothing at all i
feel like march slash april is kind of a
do or die moment for hogwarts legacy at
least in terms of 2022. and again i feel
like i always need to caveat this
because every time you talk about stuff
like this people always want to say we
don't want to rush avalanche what are
you doing don't rush the devs and i
totally agree i'm not talking about the
developers here at all i am talking
about the marketing campaign for
hogwarts legacy now on the other side of
things i also have to recognize that i
don't have the type of insight
information that would be necessary to
know maybe things aren't looking good
and the marketers don't really have a
lot to say yet maybe they're waiting on
something to kind of turn the corner
before they really start to highly
market and highly promote the game sure
there's going to be plenty of time in
the summer as well we know the summer
game fest is coming back honestly i have
no idea what's going on with e3 if it's
officially cancelled if they're bringing
it back if they're gonna try to do
something similar so who knows the point
is that if they do wait to summer there
will be plenty of opportunity there as
well but again and this is just what
boggles my mind here when people say
they're wanting news and updates it's
not like we need some vast new trailer
which don't get me wrong i would
absolutely love it's not even like we're
saying we need a release date or
anything like that we just want to hear
about the game maybe another playstation
blog post a q a from one of the
developers who's working on the game
talk to us about some of the mechanics
don't be afraid i mean sure if you want
to keep story stuff under wraps that's
fine but for a completely new original
story original game all we know right
now is third person open world action
rpg that's it and i really do think it's
important to give players some type of
expectation in advance for the type of
game that they're going to be
experiencing i talked on this channel
about how enemy camps are going to be in
the game and that set off a huge
discussion in the hogwarts legacy fandom
some people very thrilled by that idea
some people very concerned and worried
by that idea that these are going to be
boring repetitive things that get in the
way and so i really just don't see the
harm in talking about these mechanics
and talking about how the spell casting
is gonna work you don't have to reveal
every single spell that's gonna be in
the game but talk to us about the
gameplay let us know
what we're going to be able to expect
because i think it will only increase
and build the hype for the game now i
mentioned a question relating to canon
at the very beginning of this video and
troy levitt he's done a couple of
interviews recently former dev who
worked on the game the most recent one
was with colin moriarty on his sacred
symbols plus podcast i watched the whole
thing it's a very interesting interview
if you're only interested in hogwarts
legacy there's really not a lot there
about hogwarts legacy but there was one
incredibly interesting snippet that i'm
going to play for you here and we
actually got a little bit of crossover
back and forth like on cars 2
we had to come up with just a little
story here we had we had to come up with
some sort of acronym for the uh the
racing
universe that you were in we came with
this idea of chrome uh which was command
headquarters for recon operations and
motorized espionage right anyway so that
was in the game that was our excuse for
what was going on the game well they
liked it so much at pixar that if you
watch the movie cars 2 chrome is the
name of the secret spy organization that
finn mcmissile works for so that came
from the game world back to what's
called the movie world so that sort of
that sort of interaction i think is
wonderful and that's why like on
hogwarts legacy where we're at now i'm
like i i tell guys at the studio this
might be canon at some point in the
future because they're so deep in the
property and trying to treat it with so
much respect and authenticity that that
it just dovetails in really well and i
think that's what avalanche is good at
is is
making ips feel right i love this little
tidbit from troy i think this is a
fascinating look into the world of video
games and how they kind of play back and
forth with the main property quote
unquote which in this case would be like
the movie when he's talking about cars
so i really do love this idea of them
making something in hogwarts legacy that
is so impactful and so beloved by wb and
maybe even jk rowling that they say hey
you know what we could use that in the
next fantastic beasts movie or if there
are more books in the future some of
those elements could actually come into
play wb has actually spoken officially
about this in some capacity on the
hogwarts legacy website there are two
questions in the faq that relate
directly to story the first one here is
hogwarts legacy an original story and
this is where we get the whole spiel
about hogwarts legacy being an open
world single player action rpg set in
the 1800's visiting world but it's
actually the preceding question before
that that really gets into how hogwarts
legacy kind of fits into the overall
canon of the universe and it's this
question here how does hogwarts legacy
fit into the harry potter wizarding
world and then here's their answer word
for word directly from
while poor key games are not direct
adaptations of the books and films the
games are firmly rooted in the harry
potter universe while remaining true to
jk rowling's original work port key
games developers chart new territory by
creating fresh ways for fans to immerse
themselves in the wizarding world close
quote and this is why i'm actually super
excited about avalanche being the devs
for this game again back to troy levitt
who right now is really one of the only
people from inside avalanche who was
previously inside avalanche that are
talking about what the culture is like
there and one of the things that gets me
super excited is that he keeps going
back to in every interview he does he
talks about this idea that avalanche is
so good at really getting into the ip
understanding the ip understanding what
people love about it understanding what
the creators of the world love about it
and what they want to be included and
then finding a way to translate that
into video games and even though they've
never worked on a game quite like this
before that being an open world action
rpg this is what does give me hope that
even though they're relatively unknown
in this space they could definitely
still create an incredibly memorable and
enjoyable experience because of the fact
that they're so good at getting into the
ip if you look at what they've created
in the past you say well they've done
mostly kids games and while that's true
you have to consider the audience and
you have to consider the ip that they
were working on i mean disney bought
them because of their ability to do this
exact thing and when you think about a
company like disney i mean they're not
gonna go just by anyone to take their
treasured beloved ip and translate them
into video games so what would you guys
think about something from hogwarts
legacy actually becoming official
wizarding world approved by jk rowling
canon that possibly shows up later in
the series let me know in the comments
below i can't wait to hear from you as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon